[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'habitude cyril me rejoins là il n'est
pas là est ce que voulait tout de suite
une question ça m'arrange un petit peu
regardé bonjour je m'appelle muriel je
voulais savoir si entre les chroniqueurs
et avait beaucoup d'amour et d'un trade
parce que franchement quand on les
regarde séparément ils ont quand même
tous des têtes de petits pourri je
comprends votre question chère muriel
car c'est vrai que la plupart des gens
autour de cette table n'inspire pas
confiance
maintenant pour ce soir évidemment dans
ce soir c'est pire allez les
chroniqueurs ont l'air sournois comme ça
mais mais pourtant ils sont très
solidaires entre eux même si à l'écran
ça se voit pas toujours comme le jour je
sais pas où vous souvenez mais c'était
isabelle qui devait badigeonner
jean-michel avec du miel pendant qu'il
chantait du michel sardou en karaoké
dans une voiture conduite par cyril avec
le père noël sur la banquette arrière
je ne me demandez pas d'expliquer la
cohérence de sa tenue ça s'appelait le
babacar
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
107e minute
c
[Musique]
j'ai une pensée pour tous les lapons qui
subit zombies j'aime en ce moment 200 en
laponie aux toilettes je veux pas savoir
où il faut ça qu'ils atteignent c'est
c'est un peu la mascotte de l'émission a
le double il quitte tout le monde lève
dehors par exemple je vais vous révéler
un petit secret ce soit comme l est pas
là ça va pas la gêner comme les pudiques
pendant les pubs mathieu a besoin de la
bougie dans tous les sens comme si
c'était ça pollue ça n'allait pas du
tout à quelqu'un à nicolas pernikoff oui
vous allez voir en voulant être
protecteur va avoir une réflexion un peu
malheureuse la boulette de la semaine
merde oui c'est le clip de cette chanson
c'est aujourd'hui la ville a choisi le
caire comme son image de choix ce clip
et les deux mois précédents tennis n
excuse pour vous montrer cela il n'y a
que nous qui savons comment c'était
vraiment
cependant quand vous n'êtes pas gentil
en fait on fait pas son âge plutôt oui
non mais on fait à 92 en continu mais
non les orties ça revient sans aller
jusque même c'est votre pudeur comme on
sent qu'ils osent pas encore nicolas
gillet de la retenait 2010 est
d'ailleurs mal mais quand je vais me
lâcher je vais me lâcher les autres
c'est fini ça fait longtemps que le
respect ils ont revendu sur le bon coin
c'est terrible quand il parle à isabelle
tu as l'impression qu'à hésitant mamie à
la maison dans cette injustice a dit
quelle horreur regardez
[Applaudissements]
l'entité
au niveau entre est dans l'équipe on
peut aussi compter sur bien d'un vrai
vue qui s'est fixé une mission cette
année je ne sais pas j'ai appris en
regardant les offres trouver un mec pour
daniel moreau le gala difficulté ça lui
fait pas peur c'est saint bernard de
l'accouplement
est-ce qu'on va se dire la vérité elle a
la dalle daniel duquenne invités passent
bernard le branche séjourna on va sauver
l'algérie dont vous vous souvenez de ça
oui je pense qu'il est temps de faire un
point sur la vie sulfureuse de daniel
[Musique]
et aux environnements kazim bel et bien
m
simon hull
car emporté frappé balle de match
chinois à lui maintenant on a attend
parce que bernard il est venu me voir
les yeux tu sais de vraiment la queue
entre les jambes
essien je vérifier c'est vrai merci
chaude à jour je raconte que votre maman
on regarde toutes les éditions il ya
mais c'est pas de remontrances yabassi
j'ai un petit débriefing a alors on
rentre en mêlent dans la non mise à caen
sont pas content quand même assez c'est
vrai tu n'as pas de quoi on échange
field en tout cas c'est une belle
introduction pour le top gène ans
j'avais tous ces petits moments étranges
de tpb
[Musique]
le médecin qui vont le rally challenge
le médecin a relevé le challenge
[Musique]
ça fait mal
haoues il avait qui s'est déjà fait
qu'elle se mêle de bourrins plusieurs
jours
[Musique]
bonjour
c'est bon on regarde on voit là je ne
vais pas prêt tout voilà maman maman
meshkini et ce soir je vais faire un
truc là j'ai offert cinq cd de jennifer
ils seront dédicacés par jennifer voilà
ils ont été cassées par dès l'hiver ils
sont efficaces et par dès l'hiver c'est
surtout à cause d'une tendance bas qui
dure depuis déjà quelques années on peut
le dire le mot la levrette oui à la tête
de la personne
[Musique]
même vous révéler quelque chose la
semaine dernière j'ai fait l'émission
j'avais la chance j'ai dis à personne
que j'écoute quand même
[Musique]
quelqu'un lui aurait donné la réponse
pour savoir où se trouvait le siège
gagnant ou la scène partir et partir
plateau sans avoir le ou pas c'est grave
ça
[Musique]
bravant courageux sur six derniers
expriment aujourd'hui je fais aussi le
monde et c'est vrai qu'elle a posé
toutes les questions non on se rend
compte que tu fais de laetitia alors
pour se repérer par le téléphone en fait
c'est l'assistant vocal qui s'appelle
syrie qui s'est déclenchée va lui parler
je dis alors le fait qu'une la semaine
d'après vous c'est qui le faux cuba
dominant qui s'occupa pas le faux cul
buzz jean-michel bien ses camarades
c'est ça c est lors de la venue de
jennyfer vous savez le voit la
différence entre le live de la chanteuse
et le retour plateau on a eu deux titres
on a de la chance d'avoir deux titres ce
soir merci jennifer et musiciens bras
volume basiji scène
merci la tournée de jennifer partout en
france
[Applaudissements]
un génie un joli week-end à genève
escroquerie est ce que ça vous dirait
d'aller faire un petit tour au bistrot
même si en disant ça je me dis que vous
avez ça vous dirait calme-toi milices et
c'est un lancement ça fait très
longtemps que j'ai pas fait et on l'a
beaucoup réclamaient les gens me
disaient oh pourquoi ça ne vient pas me
touche pas voilà non peut-être que ça
que je vous rappelle le principe je
prends des extraits de thé pmt jeu les
ralentis et d'un seul coup une
impression que tout le monde est bourré
ce n'est qu'une illusion
enfin je crois ou pas certains
chroniqueurs franchement j'ai un doute
[Musique]
non la multiplication des formats 6 à
vesoul sait que slim shaddy beaucoup de
bagages
je m'appelle un bout de plage c'est le
meilleur pour vous jean pierre pernaut
ou pas c'est le meilleur et le meilleur
oui mon père par nouri sarhane oui/non
j'entends votre wii sera bien est ce que
quelqu'un vous aident à tenir debout
mais je fais construire ce que je veux
dire par durant ce qui suit
non et je suis comment je vais m'en
tenir bien dit j'aimerais jusqu'à vous
aurez la même qu'hier lui les rares
exceptions
enersys existe
l'étude il a moins refasse interpréter
[Musique]
je suis super bien et un mini bain
[Applaudissements]
vous savez c'est comme quand on est
adoubé quand on est quand on est on à la
légion d'honneur j'aurais aimé dans
l'est c'est un rêve
bélanger je vous rassure à chaque fois
vous passez l'antenne on a l'impression
qu'on n'a pas besoin de trafic et la
voilà tu es très bonne règle pour vous
dacca j'avais un peu plus doux mais
quand même ça m'a fait bizarre quand je
dis je vous mets quand même et j'ai
regardé daniel et on va parler de
géraldine
ah bon parce qu'on va commencer par la
comédie romantique la plus courte de
l'histoire alors dans maman dans ce
genre de films de spécialité cinéma peut
que confirmer mes dires
c'est toujours le même schéma au début
tout oppose un homme et une femme
au final ils terminent ensemble travaux
sur un plateau télé c'est beaucoup plus
rapide
j'avais plusieurs inspecteurs que j'ai
une nouvelle amoureuse qu'un enfant de
septembre et bim dans le cul
[Musique]
franchement matthieu delormeau si vous
allez en laponie si les gens vont pour
vous je quitte à jamais cette salle
voilà
sastre
[Musique]
je
tout ramener à la maison toit qui fuit
on n'est pas ça ça viendra chanter le
premier regard d'un bon
[Musique]
m
je veux lancer maintenant et mon vivant
cata
[Applaudissements]
un design
françoise spécialistes pyrotechnie
connais pas sa fierté clic clic avec eux
voilà c'est vous savez que ces voix là
c'est mes frères mes frères de sang que
ces leçons
et comme jean michel maire ils demandent
souvent il est où le trou ne manque
jamais
[Musique]
dans ton cul nous avons croisé double
take 2 je joue pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
singh il n'y avait qu'un nom mais désolé
mais sexuellement physiquement c'est
quand même moi c'est la plus acclamée je
la veux servir à huy